digamos que fx es igual al valor
absoluto de x 3 sobre x 3 y bueno yo
tengo curiosidad sobre el límite de fx
mientras extiende a 3 de fx mientras se
extiende a 3 y bueno con mirar esto tú
puedes ver que la función no está
definida cuando x es igual a 3 cierto
obtiene 0 sobre 0 y eso no está definido
entonces para contestar la pregunta que
nos hicimos
vamos a intentar reescribir esta función
de una manera distinta pero bueno igual
en cierta manera entonces digamos que fx
será igual a pensar en dos casos aquí
caso número uno x mayor que 3 lo escribo
con otro color
entonces dos casos x mayor que 3 y x
menor que 3 entonces para el caso de x
mayor que 3 a que se va a simplificar
esto ok bueno lo que obtendrás tú aquí
arriba será un número positivo y el
valor absoluto actual tomar el valor
absoluto de ese número positivo te lo va
igual entonces para x mayor que 3 esto
será lo mismo que x 3 sobre x 3 porque
si x es un número mayor el numerador
será positivo tomando el valor absoluto
del numerador como es positivo no va a
cambiar entonces podrías tú obtener lo
puede reescribir de esta forma para x
mayor que 3 f x será igual a 1 para x
mayor que 3 similarmente pensemos en qué
sucede cuando x es menor que 3 entonces
cuando estamos en este caso x menor que
3 aquí x 3 será un número negativo y
cuando tomas el valor absoluto entonces
será el negativo de x menos tres el
negativo de x menos 3 sobre x menos 3 lo
cual se simplifica siempre y cuando x no
sea 3 se simplifica a 1 entonces tenemos
menos 1 como resultado de este segundo
caso entonces menos 1 para x menor que 3
y de hecho hace el intento intenta con
números 3.1 3.001
de 43.5 cualquier número mayor que 3 con
eso obtendrás 1 lo mismo dividido entre
lo mismo te da 1 inténtalo también con
valores menores que 3 obtendrás menos 1
no importa qué valor sustituye por equis
pero ahora hay que visualizar la función
entonces digamos voy a dibujar aquí el
eje de las equis y luego por supuesto no
olvidemos el eje de las yes aquí está el
eje de la yes esto es igual a fx y lo
que nos interesa es x igual a 3 entonces
tenemos 1 2 y 3 4 y 5 sigue y sigue y
digamos que esto es 1 positivo 2 y acá
tenemos -1 y -2 acá están sigue y sigue
y reescribimos la función es la misma
exactamente la misma función que está
solo la reescribimos de distinta manera
y lo que decimos es que nuestra función
está indefinida en 3 pero si nuestras x
son mayores que 3 nuestra función vale 1
entonces para x mayor que 3 nuestra
función vale uno se mira así está
indefinida en tres y si x es menor que
tres nuestra función vale menos uno
entonces lo voy a cambiar de color se
mira de esta manera para x menor que 3 y
una vez más está indefinida en 3 así que
de esta manera se ve la gráfica entonces
bueno ahora vamos a intentar responder
nuestra pregunta inicial cuál es el
límite de fx mientras x se aproxima a 3
y bueno pensemos en el límite de fx
mientras se aproxima 3 desde el lado
negativo o valores menores que 3
entonces primero pensamos en el límite
mientras x se aproxima a 3 desde el lado
y ahí está y fx aquí esta anotación de
el signo menos significa que estamos
pensando en el límite mientras x se
aproxima desde el lado izquierdo
entonces en este caso si empezamos con
valores menores que 3 mientras nos
acercamos más más y cada vez más nos
supongamos que iniciamos en cero
entonces fx es igual a menos 1 en 1 f x
es igual a menos 1 en 2 f x es igual a
también a menos 1 si estás en 2.99 1999
f x será igual a menos 1 entonces en
este caso se aproxima menos 1 desde el
lado izquierdo cuando nos aproximamos
del lado izquierdo ahora pensemos en el
límite de fx mientras x se aproxima a 3
pero desde el lado positivo desde
valores mayores que 3 aquí vemos que
cuando x es igual a 5 fm x es igual a 1
cuando x es igual a 4 f x es igual a 1
cuando x es igual a 3.000 01 efe x es
igual a 1
entonces bueno tal parece ser que se
aproxima uno en este otro caso como
puedes ver aquí hay algo raro cierto hay
algo raro porque parece que nos estamos
aproximando a dos valores distintos si
nos aproximamos desde la izquierda o nos
aproximamos de la derecha o bueno si nos
estamos aproximando a dos valores
distintos entonces en este caso el
límite no existe por lo tanto el límite
no existe otra manera de decir esto es
que el libro no lo voy a poner mejor en
otro color porque yo voy a usar el
naranja entonces
aquí tengo una idea el límite de una
función f x mientras x se aproxima a un
valor sen es igual a l
y solamente si el límite de fx mientras
x se aproxima a c desde el lado negativo
es igual al límite de fx mientras x se
aproximase desde el lado positivo es
igual a l pero aquí no ocurrió eso
porque aproximándonos desde la izquierda
era menos 1 y aproximándonos desde la
derecha era 1 positivo por lo tanto no
tuvimos el mismo límite aproximándonos
por los lados entonces el límite no
existe